-Performing "Avalanche" from
their new album "Culture III"
out this Friday,
give it up for Migos!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Rapping ]
♪ Poppa was a rolling stone ♪
♪ But now I got
rolling stones in the bezel ♪
♪ Momma at home all alone ♪
♪ Hustling, trying to
keep this...together ♪
♪ Young...smoking on gas,
I'm living too fast ♪
♪ My foot on the pedal ♪
♪ If I go back to the past ♪
♪ My...ain't know we'd be
rockin' Coachella ♪
♪ If a...
ever try me or play me ♪
♪ I buy him an iced-out shovel ♪
♪ Dig ya own grave,
you played yourself ♪
♪ I put some cash
on your schedule ♪
♪ If a...ever try to
filet me, huh ♪
♪ I just sit back and let her ♪
♪ Bet she come up off
the cho, it's whatever ♪
♪ My pockets came with
extra cheddar ♪
♪ I can see through the... ♪
♪ I think that my skills
getting better ♪
♪ With a stick come in peace,
Mandela ♪
♪ I'm willing to feed whoever ♪
♪ How can I help you? ♪
♪ Nobody judge you but God ♪
♪ You can watch us
beat the odds ♪
♪ This ain't no cap, no facade ♪
♪ Young, rich, and black,
and we gon' beat the charge ♪
♪ I'm spending cash, no card ♪
♪ I'm liking her natural...,
no fraud ♪
♪ If she got a fake...,
of course, girl ♪
♪ Ain't nothin' wrong
with enhancing, it's yours ♪
♪ From the back,
from the back, we enjoy it ♪
♪ 100 racks,
I'ma attack with my boys ♪
♪ Got the clip walking out,
we be showin' ♪
♪ Anybody check clout,
we be knowin' ♪
♪ In and out,
in and out we be goin' ♪
♪ On a 757 Boeing ♪
♪ And my AP same size
as the Forum ♪
♪ Better get you some bread
where you from ♪
-♪ I spend my mills
on the crib ♪
♪ Cover myself, F&N is my... ♪
♪ I spent a dime,
go run you a drill ♪
♪ If you do the time,
come home to a meal ♪
♪ Double my seal,
sign another deal ♪
♪ G6 pills,
money give me chills ♪
♪ I make the...hit her knees,
she kneel ♪
♪ I make the stick hit
when I'm in the field ♪
♪ I made your...eat it up,
like ew ♪
♪ Spend 100 racks on the teeth,
not a grill ♪
♪ Lookin' at your diamonds
on your neck, ain't real ♪
♪ ...you a...,
let the draco kill ♪
♪ Heard what I said ♪
♪ Spinnin' your block every day
til' you're dead ♪
♪ Live on the edge,
...my meds ♪
♪ Open your legs, I...
with my stick in the bed ♪
♪ We...,
not fighting like Craig ♪
♪ Bad..., they DM,
they still in my thread ♪
♪ They ain't never
give us our cred ♪
♪ Patek rose gold
with the face ruby red ♪
♪ Put a hole in your head,
not your legs ♪
♪ Put my hands on her head,
she a pet ♪
♪ M-I-G-O, that's the set ♪
♪ ...that P.O.,
I'ma just pay it ♪
♪ White glass in my Lambo,
it look like it's albino ♪
♪ I hit your..., she say ouch,
hit a high note ♪
♪ I'm Richie Rich, like Lionel ♪
♪ Count your blessings,
don't worry about the rival ♪
♪ Grandma told me,
go read the Bible ♪
♪ Should've listened, still
look at the sky, though ♪
♪ Sifter sippin',
this not the Moscato ♪
♪ ..., I'm gifted,
I'm smokin' gelato ♪
-♪ We been the...that steppin' ♪
♪ We came in the do'
and they takin' the flow ♪
♪ Call it repo ♪
♪ My dog, he gon' bite,
no chico ♪
♪ Get hit with the draco
and make him with RICO ♪
♪ Ain't shopping Rodeo ♪
♪ You wanna see the 3 Migos,
then turn on your Vevo ♪
♪ The whip colored mayo ♪
♪ And the cheese like I ate
a bag of some Cheetos ♪
♪ They must've forgot
we the Migos ♪
♪ Straight from the naw
out the Bando ♪
♪ I done been quiet
for too long ♪
♪ I copped that Cuban,
it's two-toned ♪
♪ I heard he trappin',
they tappin' that static ♪
♪ Tell that boy,
go get a new phone ♪
♪ Out in Bel Air,
copped a new home ♪
♪ Avalanche with
the blue stone ♪
♪ I'm the..., can't find a fit ♪
♪ My neck is a fridge,
the rings and wrists ♪
♪ I retro'd the kicks ♪
♪ Ain't givin' no kiss,
I'm givin' her... ♪
♪ You staring too long,
like you seen a ghost ♪
♪ So whip out your camera,
take you a pic ♪
♪ So when you get home,
get back on your phone ♪
♪ Zoom in on the flick
and look at the drip ♪
♪ She asked me to pay for
the...to get lifted ♪
♪ I told her I'm better off
getting you a Lyft ♪
♪ Think I'ma put all my trust
in a...with no benefits ♪
♪ Tell her,
go jump off a cliff ♪
♪ I go through 230 a cup
of that purple ♪
♪ Put ice in my drink
just to keep on chill ♪
♪ ...all that talk, you
ain't been in the field ♪
♪ Open my bank account
and it give me chills ♪
♪♪
[ Applause ]